go ahead i was feeling pretty good about
our belief in the tampa bay buccaneers
coming off of their big win over
carolina and they're coming home and
they have daniel jones and the giants
and the giants had looked punchless
through the first couple of weeks of the
season and here and 28 to 10 at the half
and it's all working and mike evans
finally getting the ball the way that he
should and jameis winston getting ready
to eat a w he had that w pulled right
out of his mouth before he could chomp
down on it daniel jones and company come
from behind fueled by a chris sims
approved f-bomb tirade of daniel jones
in the second quarter they got the
attention of his teammates and helped
fuel that turnaround
daniel jones had two touchdown passes
ran for two touchdowns fourth quarter
with 116 left on the clock he scored the
game-winning touchdown and he still had
to hold on because there was time left
for the buccaneers to go down the field
they got down the field they got
themselves in field goal position rookie
matt gay another quarterback drafted by
the buccaneers missed the thirty-four
field goal ride uh wide right what did i
say quarterback quarterback i meant
kicker i'm looking at daniel jones not
quarterback another kicker drafted by
the tampa bay buccaneers he missed the
34-yard field goal wide right and the
but and the buccaneers lose the giants
win and they're going to be very happy
in new york if only for a day if only
temporarily daniel jones is the man and
uh what a debut and what a way to make
people
move on yes from eli manning you're not
gonna get the clamoring not that it was
gonna happen anyway but if if they had
been blown off the field then maybe have
some giants fans thinking that maybe we
were wrong about this yeah and even if
they're not competitive with daniel
jones you're gonna get pressure in
december to give eli manning a little
mini farewell tour
hey they play like they did yesterday
they're going to be a team that has
every reason to put their top
quarterback on the field in december
because they're going to still be alive
for a potential playoff birth well i
mean he certainly gave juice to the
football team there's no denying that
what daniel jones brought to the table
uh you know that was you could see it as
soon as the game started just whether it
was his you know aggressive nature and
trying to find completions down the
field his movement we talked about that
was good uh but i mean come on to win a
game on the road being down 28 to 10 in
your first start ever your defense you
know can't stop anything i mean the
buccaneers were making big pass plays
all over the field and daniel jones to
what the giants and give them credit to
what they saw what they saw and what
we've all seen now is a guy that just
never gets rattled he seems fine oh okay
28 to 10. i'm the same guy and you know
like you said he threw out a few f-bombs
but made some big plays and got to got
the ball to guys in their offense who
can make plays too i mean smart that way
we saw the evan ingram touchdown that
was special finding sterling shepard a
bunch of times in the second half so and
no saquon barkley i think that makes
that even uh that much more impressive
yeah barclay with a high ankle sprain he
was in a walking boot and on crutches
during and after the game yesterday
he'll have an mri today he he said that
his season isn't over which yeah it
shouldn't be over
but he could be out for a while the high
ankle sprain sometimes takes four to six
weeks
and the giants defense is a problem now
look to their problem after it was 28 to
10 at halftime they put the clamps on
the buccaneers offense into uh the
second half and all the way up until
that last drive but when you give the
buccaneers the ball back with 116. and
they have the ball on your nine with 13
seconds left that is a horrendous
display by the giants defense yeah the
buccaneers should have won that game and
and the story today in new york should
be
hey daniel jones look pretty good but
our defense is abysmal so we're not
going to win many games and i still i
still think that's the concern that the
giants need to have going forward they
have no pass rusher and no guy and they
can't cover that's not a good other than
that they're fine i mean that's that's
not a good combination this day and age
in the nfl so
yes uh the giants secondary it stinks
they're slow they can't play man-to-man
uh they have issues there and i think
you'll continue to see teams throw the
ball all over the field on them
yeah and uh look who knows what the
giants are going to do from here
offensively but if the defense isn't any
better they aren't going to be
competitive they aren't going to be able
to hang with a team like the dallas
cowboys but at least it's a win at least
it's something to build on and at least
it gives hope maybe not for 2019 but you
know you've got the foundation now with
the quarterback you can feel good about
now you can commence the process of
rebuilding around him yeah instead of
the last several years of just this
aimless where are the giants who are the
giants what are the giants going to be
now you've got a vision now you've got a
purpose now you've got a guy that you
believe can be that centerpiece of your
offense and you can feel better about it
between him and saquon barkley you can
build around that and you can maybe lure
some free agents maybe some guys who can
make a little more elsewhere they want
to come be part of it with saquon
barkley and daniel jones so so it
yesterday even if this even if they
don't win another game this year
yesterday was the kind of thing that i
think could could lay the foundation for
the giants to turn things around all
right the the browns are trying to turn
things around not that they ever were in
the right place like they're not coming
back from anything it's been years since
they were relevant 11 years since they
played on sunday night football they
finally got their shot in prime time
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports